‏eh
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان ال اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
استقيموا واستووا راسوا
واعتدلوا ارحمكم الله
الله
اكبر
وتبارك
ش
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امينين الم
را تلك ايات الكتاب وقران
مبين ربما يودوا الذين كفروا لو كانوا
مسلمين ذرهم ياكلوا ويتمتعوا ويلههم الامل
فسوف
يعلمون وما اهلكنا من قريه الا ولها كتاب
معلوم ما تسبق من امه اجلها وما
يستاخرون وقالوا يا ايها الذي نزل عليه
الذكر انك
لمجنون لو ما تاتينا
بالملائكه ان كنت من
الصادقين ما ننزل
الملائكه الا بالحق وما كانوا اذا
منظرين انا نحن نزلنا الذكر وانا له
لحافظون ولقد ارسلنا من قبلك في شيع
الاولين وما ياتيهم من رسول الا كانوا به
يستهزئون كذلك نسلكه في قلوب
المجرمين لا يؤمنون به وقد خلت سنه
الاولين ولو فتحنا عليهم بابا من
السماء فظلوا فيه
يعرجون لقالوا انما سكرت ابصارنا بل نحن
قوم
مسحورون ولقد جعلنا في
السماء بروجا
وزيناها
للناظرين
وحفظناها من كل شيطان
الرجيم الا من استرق السمع ف بعه شهاب
مبين والارض مددناها والقينا فيها رواسي
وانبتنا فيها من كل شيء
موزون وجعلنا لكم فيها معايش ومن لستم له
برازقين وان من شيء الا عندنا خزا
ئنه وما ننزله الا بقدر
معلوم وارسلنا الرياح لواقح فانزلنا من
السماء
ماء فاسقيناكموه وما انتم له
بخازنين وان لنحن نحيي
ونميت وانا لنحن نحيي ونميت ونحن
الوارثون ولقد علمنا المستقدمين منكم ولقد
علمنا المستا
اخرين
وان ربك هو يحشرهم
انه حكيم
عليم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الددين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين لقد خلقنا الانسان من صلصال من حما
مسنون
والجان خلقناه من قبل من نار
السموم واذ قال ربك
للملائكه اني خالق بشرا من صلصال من حما
مسنون فاذا سويته ونفخ ت فيه من روحي
فقعوا له
ساجدين فسجد
الملائكه كلهم
اجمعون الا ابليس ابى ان يكون مع
الساجدين قال يا ابليس ما لك الا تكون مع
الساجدين قال لم اكن لاسجد لبشر خلقته من
صلصال من حما
مسنون قال فاخرج منها فانك
رجيم وان عليك اللعنه الى يوم
الدين قال رب فانظرني الى يوم
يبعثون قال فانك من
المنظرين الى يوم الوقت
المعلوم قال رب ما اغويتني
لازينن لهم في الارض ولاغوينهم
اجمعين الا عبادك منهم
المخلصين قال هذا صراط علي
مستقيم ان عبادي ليس لك عليهم سلطان الا
من اتبعك من
الغاوين وان جهنم لم دهم
اجمعين لها سبعه
ابواب لكل باب منهم جزء
مقسوم ان المتقين في
جنات
وعيون ادخلوها بسلام
امنين ونزعنا ما في صدورهم من غل اخوانا
على سرر متق
قابلين لا يمسهم فيها نصب لا يمسهم فيها
نصب وما هم منها
بمخرجين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
[Silence]
الرحم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله
[Silence]
الرحم الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن من
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏k
‏ok
[Silence]
‏fr
‏che
صلاه القيام استقيم
واستووا
الله
اكبر بسم الله ال الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين نبئ عبادي اني انا الغفور الرحيم وان
عذابي هو العذاب
الاليم ونبئهم عن ضيف ابراهيم اذ دخلوا
عليه فقالوا سلاما قال انا منكم
وجلون
قالوا لا توجل انا نبشرك بغلام
عليم قال
ابشرتموني على ان مسني الكبر فبم
تبشرون قالوا بشرناك بالحق فلا تكن من
القانطين قال ومن يقنط من رحمه ربه الا
الضال
قال فما خطبكم ايها
المرسلون قالوا انا ارسلنا الى قوم
مجرمين الا ال لوط انا لمنجوهم
اجمعين الا امراته قدرنا انها لمن
الغابرين فلما
جاء ال لوط المرسل
قال انكم قوم
منكرون قالوا بل جئناك بما كانوا فيه
يمترون واتيناك بالحق وانا
لصادقون فاسر باهلك بقطع من الليل واتبع
ادبارهم ولا يلتفت منكم احد وامضوا حيث
تؤمرون
وقضينا اليه ذلك الامر ان دابر
هؤلاء
مقطوع
مصبحين
وجاء اهل المدينه
يستبشرون قال ان
هؤلاء ضيفي فلا
تفضحون واتقوا الله ولا
تخزون قالوا اولم ننهك عن
العالمين قال
هؤلاء بناتي ان كنتم
فاعلين لعمرك انهم لفي سكرتهم
يعمهون فاخذتهم الصيحه
مشرقين فجعلنا عاليها سافلها وامطرنا
عليهم حجاره من سجيل
ان في ذلك لايه للمتوسمين
ان في ذلك لايات للمتوسمين
وانها
لبسبيل
مقيم ان في ذلك لايه
للمؤمنين وان كان اصحاب الايكه لظالمين
فانتقمنا منهم
وانهما لبامام
مبين ولقد كذب اصحاب الحجر
المرسلين
واتيناهم اياتنا فكانوا عنها
معرضين وكانوا ينحتون من الجبال بيوتا
امنين فاخذتهم الصيحه مصبحين فما اغنى
عنهم ما كانوا
يكسبون وما خلقنا السماوات والارض وما
بينهما الا
بالحق وان الساعه
لاتيه فاصفح الصفح
الجميل ان ربك هو الخلاق
العليم ولقد اتيناك
سبعا من المثاني والقران
عظيم لا تمدن عينيك الى ما متعنا به
ازواجا منهم ولا تحزن عليهم واخفض جناحك
للمؤمنين وقل اني انا
النذير
المبين كما
انزلنا على المقتسمين
الذين ج القران
عضين فوربك
لنسالنهم
اجمعين عما كانوا
يعملون فاصدع بما تؤمر واعرض عن
المشركين
انا كفيناك المستهزئين الذين يجعلون مع
الله الها
اخر الذين يجعلون مع الله الها اخر فسوف
يعلمون ولقد نعلم
انك يضيق صدرك بما
يقولون فسبح بحمد ربك وكن من
الساجدين واعبد ربك حتى ياتيك
اليقين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اتى امر الله فلا
تستعجلوه سبحانه وتعالى عما
يشركون ينزل
الملائكه بالروح من امره على من
يشاء من عباده ان
انذروا ان انذروا انه لا اله الا انا
فاتقون خل السماوات والارض بالحق تعالى
عما
يشركون خلق
الانسان من
نطفه فاذا هو
خصيم
مبين
والانعام خلقها لكم فيها دفء ومنافع ومنها
تاكلون ولكم فيها جمال حين حون وحين
تسرحون وتحمل اثقالكم الى بلد لم تكونوا
بالغيه الا بشق
الانفس ان ربكم لرؤوف
رحيم والخيل والبغال والحمير لتركبوها
وزينه ويخلق ما لا
تعلمون وعلى الله قصد السبيل ومنها
جائر ولو
شاء لهداكم
اجمعين هو الذي انزل من
السماء
ماء لكم منه شراب ومنه شجر فيه
تسيمون ينبت لكم به الزرع الزيتون
والنخيل والاعناب ومن كل الثمرات
ان في ذلك لايه
لقوم
يتفكرون وسخر لكم الليل والنهار والشمس
والقمر والنجوم
مسخرات
بامره ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يعقلون وما ذرا لكم في الارض مختلفا اياته
ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يذكرون وما درا لكم في الارض مختلفا
الوانه ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يذكرون وهو الذي سخر البحر لتاكلوا منه
لحما
طريا لتاكلوا منه لحما طريا
وتستخرجون حليه
تلبسونها وترى الفلك فيه مواخر لتبتغوا من
فضله
ولعلكم ولعلكم
تشكرون وهو الذي سخر البحر لتاكلوا منه
لحما طري
وتستخرجوا منه حليه
تلبسونها وترى الفلك مواخر فيه ولتبتغوا
من فضله ولعلكم
تشكرون والقى في الارض رواسي ان تميد بكم
وانهارا وسبلا لعلكم
تهتدون
وعلامات وبالنجم هم يهتدون
افمن يخلق كمن لا يخلق افلا
تذكرون وان تعدوا نعمه الله لا
تحصوها ان الله لغفور
رحيم والله يعلم ما تسرون وما
تعلنون والذين يدعون من دون الله لا
يخلقون شيئا وهم ي
خلقون اموات غير
احياء وما يشعرون ايان
يبعثون الهكم اله واحد فالذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره قلوبهم منكره وهم
مستكبرون لا جرم ان الله يعلم ما يسرون
وما يعلنون
انه لا يحب
المستكبرين واذا قيل لهم ماذا انزل ربكم
قالوا اساطير
الاولين ليحملوا اوزارهم كامله يوم
القيامه ومن اوزار الذين
يضلونهم بغير علم الا
ساء ما
يزرون قد مكر الذين من قبلهم فاتى الله
بنيانهم من القواعد فخر عليهم السقف من
فوقهم فخر عليهم السقف من فوقهم واتاهم
العذاب من حيث لا
يشعرون ثم يوم القيامه يخزيهم ويقول اين
شركائي الذين كنتم ت
شا قون
فيهم قال الذين اوتوا العلم ان الخزي
اليوم
والسوء على
الكافرين الذين
تتوفاهم
الملائكه ظالمي
انفسهم فالقوا السلم ما كنا نعمل من
سوء بلى ان ان الله عليم بما
كنتم
تعملون فادخلوا ابواب
جهنم خالدين فيها فلبئس مثوى
المتكبرين الله
اكبر سمع
الله من
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
استقيم سجده التلاوه ان شاء الله
رك ان شاء الله
استقم الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقيل للذين اتقوا ماذا انزل ربكم
قالوا خيرا للذي احسنوا في هذه الدنيا
حسنه ولدار الاخره خير ولنعم دار
المتقين جنات عدن يدخلونها تجري من تحتها
الانهار لهم فيها ما
يشاؤون كذلك يجزي الله
المتقين الذين تتوفاهم الملا
ئكه طيبين يقولون سلام عليكم ادخلوا الجنه
بما كنتم
تعملون هل ينظرون الا ان تاتيهم
الملائكه او ياتي امر
ربك كذلك فعل الذين من قبلهم وما ظلمهم
الله ولكن كانوا انفسهم
يظلمون فاصابهم سيئات ما عملوا وحاق بهم
ما كانوا به
يستهزئون وقال الذين اشركوا لو شاء الله
ما عبدنا من دونه من شيء نحن ولا
اباؤنا ولا
حرمنا ولا حرمنا من دون من
شيء كذلك فعل الذين من قبلهم فهل على
الرسل الا البلاغ
المبين ولقد بعثنا في كل امه رسولا ان
اعبدوا الله واجتنبوا
الطاغوت فمنهم من هدى الله ومنهم من حقت
عليه
الضلاله فسيروا في الارض
فانظروا كيف كان عاقبه
المكذبين ان تحرص على هداهم فان الله لا
يهدي من يضل وما لهم من
ناصرين واقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم لا يبعث
الله من
يموت بلى وعدا عليه حقا ولا لكن اكثر
الناس لا
يعلمون ليبين لهم الذي يختلفون فيه وليعلم
الذين كفروا انهم كانوا
كاذبين انما قولنا لشيء اذا اردناه ان
نقول له كن
فيكون والذين هاجروا في الله من بعد ما
ظلموا لنبوئنهم
في الدنيا حسنه ولاجر الاخره اكبر لو
كانوا
يعلمون الذين صبروا وعلى ربهم
يتوكلون وما ارسلنا من قبلك الا رجالا
نوحي اليهم فاسالوا اهل الذكر ان كنتم لا
تعلمون بالبينات
والزبر وانزلنا اليك الذكر لتبين للناس ما
نزل اليهم ولعلهم
يتفكرون افامن الذين مكروا السيئات ان
يخسف الله بهم الارض او ياتيهم العذاب من
حيث لا
يشعرون او ياخذهم في تقلبهم فما هم
بمعجزين
او ياخذهم على تخوف فان ربكم لرؤوف
رحيم اولم يروا الى ما خلق الله من شيء
يتفي ظلاله عن اليمين
والشمائل
سجدا سجدا لله وهم
داخرون ولله يسجد ما في السماوات وما في
الارض من
دابه
والملائكه
وهم وهم لا
يستكبرون يخافون
ربهم من فوقهم
ويفعلون ما
يؤمرون الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر وقال الله لا تتخذوا الهين اثنين
انما هو اله واحد فاياي فارهبون
وله ما في السماوات والارض وله الدين
واصبا افغير الله
تتقون وما بكم من نعمه فمن
الله ثم اذا مسكم الضر فاليه
تجارون ثم اذا كشف الضر عنكم اذا فر ق
منكم بربهم
يشركون ليكفروا بما اتيناهم فتمتعوا فسوف
تعلمون ويجعلون لما لا يعلمون نصيبا مما
رزقناهم ت الله
لتسالن عما كنتم
تفترون ويجعلون لله البنات سبحانه ولهم ما
يشتهون واذا بشر احدهم بالانثى ظل وجهه
مسودا وهو
كظيم يتوارى من القوم من
سوء ما بشر به ايمسكه على هون ام يدسه في
التراب الا
ساء ما يحكم
للذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره مثل
السوء ولله المثل الاعلى وهو العزيز
الحكيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين ولو يؤاخذ الله الناس بظلمهم ما ترك
عليها من
دابه ولكن يؤخرهم الى اجل
مسمى فاذا
جاء اجله لا يستاخرون ساعه ولا
يستقدمون ويجعلون لله ما
يكرهون وتصف السنتهم الكذب ان لهم
الحسنى لا جرم ان لهم النار
وانهم
مفرطون ت الله لقد ارسلنا الى امم من قبلك
فزين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم فهو وليهم اليوم
ولهم عذاب
اليم وما انزلنا عليك الكتاب الا لتبين
لهم الذي اختلفوا فيه وهدى ورحمه لقوم
يؤمنون والله انزل من
السماء ما
فاحيا به الارض بعد
موتها ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يسمعون وان لكم في الانعام لعبره نسقيكم
مما في بطونه من بين فرث ودم
لبنا لبنا
خالصا
سائغا
للشاربين
ومن ثمرات
النخيل والاعناب تتخذون منه سكرا ورزقا
حسنا ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يعقلون واوحى ربك الى النحل ان اتخذي من
الجبال بيوتا ومن الشجر ومما
يعرشون ثم كلي من كل الثمرات فاسلكي سبل
ربك
ذللا يخرج من بطونها شراب مختلف الوانه
فيه
شفاء
للناس ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يتفكرون والله خلقكم ثم
يتوفاكم
ومنكم من يرد الى ارذل العمر لكي لا يعلم
بعد علم شيئا ان الله
عليم
قدير والله فضل بعضكم على بعض في الرزق
فما الذين فضلوا
برادي رزقهم على ما ملكت ايمانهم فهم في
سواء اف بنعمه الله
يجحدون والله جعل لكم من
انفسكم
ازواجا وجعل
لكم من
ازواجكم بنين
وحفده ورزقكم من
الطيبات افبالباطل
يؤمنون وبنعمه الله هم يكفرون
ويعبدون من دون الله ما لا يملك لهم رزقا
من السماوات والارض شيئا ولا
يستطيعون فلا تضربوا لله
الامثال ان الله يعلم
وانتم لا
تعلمون الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏ok السلام
عله الرحمن الرح على رس
[Silence]
الكريم
‏man
حسان بث لو لم تكن له ايه مبينه لكان
منظره
بالخبر
[Silence]
كان سكوته اكثر من
كلامه عليه
[Silence]
من
الذره قتل الانسان ما اكفر ايي
خل
100% ليس لك سن تفلق وليس لك ضرس تحن وليس
لك يد تبطش وليس لك وليس
لر
الله ومن
نعمره
القق
[Silence]
الله
‏can
‏c i dress this when i cross the b
so of ask you do you have any guns said
of not then they say do you
have was ask ever ask
some
[Silence]
‏and
‏over
[Silence]
‏there
‏so he said no i now me likeing gu so he
comes the cares i
me he said you came the the gu takes
passs at my
me you ever been
arrest
‏arr english you ever been arrest
said you know when scared youing
theist ask
again
noting ever arrest
non
[Silence]
‏te
انه من نقش بالحب
[Silence]
فقلق
‏my
‏working te certificate andes home so if
not actually do something and
not
ح
[Silence]
الرح
الله
[Silence]
‏some
ان
[Silence]
الله اجمع في
الناس
[Silence]
‏my wife
ir
[Silence]
‏appr
ال
[Silence]
‏find تم بلام تعتذر
مندا واذا قمت الصلاه فصل صلاه
مصلا
[Silence]
‏father
‏as
[Silence]
‏people
‏always
ان شاء الله السلام علكم
وبركاته استقيم واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف
سدوا
الخلل الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين ضرب الله مثلا عبدا مملوكا لا يقدر
على
شيء ومن
رزقنا ومن رزقناه منا رزقا حسنا فهو ينفق
منه سرا
وجهرا هل
يستوون
الحمد لله بل اكثرهم لا
يعلمون وضرب الله مثل الرجلين احدهما ابكم
لا يقدر على شيء وهو كل على
مولاه وهو كل على مولاه اينما يوجهه لا
ياتي
بخير هل يستوي هو ومن
يامر بالعدل وهو على صراط
مستقيم ولله غيب السماوات والارض وما امر
الساعه وما امر الساعه الا كلمح البصر او
هو
اقرب ان الله على كل شيء
قدير والله اخرجكم
من بطون
امهاتكم لا تعلمون
شيئا وجعل لكم السمع والابصار والافئده
لعلكم
تشكرون الم يروا الى الطير
مسخرات في جو
السماء ما
يمسكهن الا الله
ان في ذلك لايه لقوم
يؤمنون ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يؤمنون والله جعل لكم من بيوتكم
سكنا وجعل لكم من جلود الانعام بيوتا
تستخفونها
تستخفونها يوم ظعنكم ويوم اقامتكم ومن
اصوافها ومن اصوافها واوبارها
واشعارها اثاثا ومتاعا الى
حين والله جعل لكم مما خلق
ضلالا والله جعل له
مما خلق
ظلالا وجعل لكم من الجبال
اكنانا وجعل لكم سرابيل تقيكم الحر
وسرابيل ل تقيكم
باسكم كذلك يتم نعمته عليكم لعلكم
تسلمون
فان ولوا
فانما عليك البلاغ
المبين يعرفون نعمه الله ثم
ينكرونها
واكثرهم
الكافرون ويوم نبعث في ويوم نبعث من كل
امه شهيدا ثم لا يؤذن للذين كفروا
ثم لا يؤذن للذين كفروا ولا هم
يستعتبون واذا راى الذين ظلموا
العذاب فلا يخفف عنهم ولا هم
ينظرون واذا راى الذين اشركوا
شركاءهم قالوا
ربنا قالوا ربنا
هؤلاء
شركاؤنا الذين كنا ندعو من دونك فالقوا
اليهم القول انكم
لكاذبون والقوا الى الله يومئذ السلم وضل
عنهم ما كانوا
يفترون الذين فروا وصدوا عن سبيل الله
زدناهم
عذابا زدناهم
عذابا فوق العذاب بما كانوا
يفسدون ويوم نبعث في من كل
امه شهيدا عليهم من
انفسهم ويوم نبعث في كل
انفسهم وجئنا بك شهيدا على
هؤلاء ونزلنا عليك الكتاب تبيانا لكل
شيء
وهدى
ورحمه وبشرى
للمسلمين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذي قربى وينهى عن
الفحشاء
والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واوفوا بعهد الله اذا عاهدتم ولا
تنقضوا الايمان بعد
توكيدها ولا تنقضوا الايمان بعد توكيدها
وقد جعلتم الله عليكم
فيلا ان الله يعلم ما
تفعلون ولا تكونوا كالتي نقضت غزلها من
بعد قوه انكاثا
تتخذون تتخذون ايمانكم
دخلا بينكم ان تكون
امه هي اربى من امه
انما يبلوكم الله به
وليبين لكم يوم القيامه ما كنتم فيه
تختلفون ولو
شاء الله لجعلكم
امه
واحده ولكن يضل من
يشاء ويهدي من
يشاء ولتس الن
عما كنتم
تعملون ولا تتخذوا ايمانكم دخلا بينكم
فتزل قدم بعد
ثبوتها وتذوق
السوء بما صددتم عن سبيل الله ولكم عذاب
عظيم ولا تشتروا بايات الله
ثمنا
قليلا ولا تشتروا بعهد الله ثمنا
قليلا
ان
الله
انما عند الله هو خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون ما عند الله ما عندكم
ينفد وما عند الله
باق
ولنجزين الذين صبروا اجرهم باحسن ما كانوا
يعملون من عمل صالحا من ذكر او انثى وهو
مؤمن
فلنحيينه
حياه طيبه
ولنجزينهم اجرهم باحسن ما كانوا
يعملون فاذا قرات القران فاستعذ بالله من
الشيطان
الرجيم انه ليس له سلطان على الذين نوا
وعلى ربهم
يتوكلون انما سلطانه على الذين
يتولونه والذين هم به
مشركون واذا بدلنا
ايه مكان ايه والله اعلم والله اعلم بما
ينزل قالوا ان انما انت مفتر بل اكثرهم لا
يعلمون قل نزله روح
القدس من ربك بالحق
ليثبت ليثبت الذين
امنوا
وهدى وبشرى
للمسلمين ولقد نعلم انهم يقولون ان انما
يعلمه بشر لسان الذي يلحدون اليه
اعجمي وهذا لسان عربي
مبين ان الذين لا يؤمنون بايات الله لا
يهديهم الله ولهم عذاب
عظيم ولهم عذاب اليم
انما يفتري الكذب الذين لا يؤمنون بايات
الله
واولئك هم
الكاذبون من كفر من بعد ايمانه الا من
اكره وقلبه
مطمئن
بالايمان من كفر بالله من بعد ايمانه الا
من اكره وقلبه
مطمئن
بالايمان ولكن من شرح بالكفر صدرا فعليهم
غضب فعليهم غضب من الله
واولئك هم
الخاسرون
ولهم عذاب
عظيم ذلك
بانهم استحب الحياه الدنيا على الاخره وان
الله لا يهدي القوم
الكافرين
اولئك الذين خسروا
انفسهم اول ك الذين طبع الله على سمعهم
وابص اولئك الذين طبع الله على قلوبهم
وسمعهم
وابصارهم
واولئك هم
الغافلون لا جرم انهم في الاخره هم
الخاسرون ثم ان ربك للذين هاجروا من بعد
ما
فتنوا ثم جاهدوا
وصبروا
ان ربك من بعدها لغفور
رحيم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
سبحان
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يوم تاتي كل نفس تجادل عن
نفسها وتوفى كل
نفس ما عملت وهم لا يظلمون وضرب الله مثلا
قريه كانت امنه
مطمئنه ياتيها
رزقها ياتيها رزقها رغدا من كل مكان فكثرت
بانعم الله
فاذاقها الله لباس الجوع والخوف بما كانوا
يصنعون ولقد
جاءهم
رسول منهم
فكذبوه فاخذهم العذاب وهم
ظالمون فكلوا مما رزقكم الله حلالا
طيبا واشكروا نعمه الله
ان
كنتم واشكروا نعمه الله عليكم ان كنتم
اياه
تعبدون واشكروا نعمه الله ان كنتم اياه
تعبدون انما حرم عليكم الميته والدم ولحم
الخنزير ولحم الخن ير وما اهل لغير الله
به فمن اطر غير باغ ولا عاد فان الله غفور
رحيم ولا تقولوا لما تصف السنتكم الكذب
هذا
حلال وهذا
حرام هذا حلال وهذا حرام لتفت على الله
الكذب ان الذين يفترون على الله الكذب لا
يفلحون متاع
قليل ولهم عذاب
اليم وعلى الذين هادوا حرمنا ما قصصنا
عليك من
قبل وما ظلمناهم ولا
كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون ثم ان ربك للذين عملوا
السوء
بجهاله ثم
تابوا ثم تابوا من بعد ذلك
واصلحو
ان ربك من بعدها
لغفور
يم الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعب نبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ان ابراهيم كان امه قانه لله حني
ولم يك من
المشركين شاكرا
لانعمه اجتباه وهداه الى صراط
مستقيم
واتيناه في الدنيا حسنه وانه في الاخره
لمن
الصالحين ثم اوحينا اليك ان اتبع مله
ابراهيم حنيفا
حنيفا وما كان من
المشركين انما جعل السبت على الذين
اختلفوا فيه وان ربك ليحكم بينهم يوم
القيامه فيما كانوا فيه
يختلفون ادع الى سبيل ربك بالحكمه
والموعظه الحسنه
وجادلهم بالتي هي احسن ان ربك هو اعلم من
ان ربك هو اعلم من ضل عن سبيله وهو اعلم
بالمهتدين
ان ربك هو اعلم بمن ضل عن سبيله وهو اعلم
وان عاقبتم فعاقبوا بمثل ما
عوقبتم به ولئن صبرتم لهو خير
للصابرين واصبر وما صبرك الا
بالله ولا تحزن عليهم ولا تك في
ضيق مما
يمكرون ان الله مع الذين اتقوا والذين
هم
محسنون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
‏m
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله لا اله الا الله
صلاه رتر استقيم واستو
يرحمكم الله اكبر سبحانك اللههم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ضالين
امين والتين والزيتون وطور
سينين وهذا البلد
الامين لقد خلقنا الانسان في احسن
تقويم ثم رددناه اسفل سافل الا الذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات فلهم اجر غير
ممنون فما يكذبك بعد
بالدين اليس الله باحكم
الحاكمين بلا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحم
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
امين اقرا بسسم ربك الذي خلق خلق
الانسان من علق اقرا وربك
الاكرم الذي علم بالقلم علم
الانسان ما لم يعلم كلا ان
الانسان يطغى ان راه
استغنى ان الى ربك
الرجع الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
سلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذي
الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده ربنا لك الحمد
حمدا كثيرا طيبا مباركا اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اللهم احسن عاقبتنا في الامور كلها
واجرنا من خزي الدنيا وعذاب الاخره ربنا
اتنا من لدنك رحمه وهيئ لنا من امرنا رشدا
اللهم وفقنا لما تحب وترضى وتوفنا وانت
راض عنا يا
كريم اللهم يا ذا الجلال والاكرام يا عزيز
يا جبار يا منتقم اللهم انتقم لعبادك
الذين غصبوا على انفسهم واموالهم وارضهم
وكرامتهم اللهم انتقم لهم يا رب العالمين
انتقم لهم ممن اذاهم وممن اعان عليهم
اللهم ارغم انوف المتكبرين
والمستكبرين
والمتجبرين والمتجبرين في الارض بغير الحق
يا رب العالمين اللهم اقتلهم بددا واحصهم
عددا ولا تذر منهم احدا
لا اله الا انت سبحانك
انا كنا من
الظالمين وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
سبحان
[Silence]
‏ja
‏l